welcome to lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events
and webinars
this is the first time i've ever
presented at a virtual event
lab roots makes it easy to network with
other scientists
and reach farther and wider in your
industry by attending webinars and
virtual events
online tissue slice and then go in and
do next generation sequencing either
sequencing by synthesis
like as an aluminum or sequencing by
litigation lab roots provides fast
access to news
research and trends along with the
latest updates in scientific research
straight from the source expand your
circle faster
and connect with the right people gain
access to new research
and increase your knowledge
i can reach a number of people that i
wouldn't normally be able to reach
people that uh are in countries where
travel is more difficult or which i
haven't traveled to
and certainly students who can't afford
to attend a lot of the presentations
you think about this format for a
scientific exchange
i don't travel anymore so this is the it
is what is left for me and i am so
pleased
being able to do this facetime
communication between scientists
between scientists and listeners could
be a very effective way of
stimulating and making the advance of
science
even more accelerated than it is today
our community of followers relies on our
content to discuss
new emerging approaches in science today
join the discussion
with a large active and helpful science
community lab roots makes it easy to
connect
collaborate and learn with peers from
around the globe
lab roots brings you together with
experts and leaders
in your field join lab roots free
today